we haven't heard much from Kellyanne
Conway in the national media
after that pathetic embarrassment of the
so-called Bowling Green massacre that of
course never happened and doesn't exist
that she mentioned on TV she mentioned
that and then basically stops doing
national media I don't know if she's
been in timeout long enough that now
she's out of it or if things are just
getting so desperate for the Trump
administration that they figured hey
let's put her back on TV but she
appeared on a number of programs over
the weekend including on Fox News to
talk about the growing Trump Russia
scandal let's start with her appearance
on Fox and Friends she went on Fox &
Friends to talk about how it's just no
big deal that Donald from junior met
with a Russian lawyer and a Russian
lobbyist and blah blah blah blah blah
and I want to prepare you for what we're
about to see in here she is about to
move the goal posts and use projection
and blame Hillary to try to distract
from what's going on but she moves the
goal posts herself by accusing others of
having moved the goalposts sit down get
the kids out of the room because this is
really really bad we don't want to
listen I'd show them Janet Jackson's
breasts ten times before I showed them
the atrocity that I'm about to show I'm
not even going to watch yeah Pat you
Pat's leaving the room himself here is
clip number one of Kellyanne Conway's
immediate implosion over the weekend
even the goal posts have been moved I
mean we were promised systemic hard
evidence of systemic sustained furtive
collusion that not only interfered with
our election process but indeed dictated
the electoral outcome and one of the
only people who says that seriously
these days is still Hillary Clinton and
I one believes it we know why she lost
it's obvious and and frankly you know
when I was campaign manager in those
last several months I you know when I
needed negative information about
Hillary Clinton I don't have to go very
far I looked at infiltrate Clinton yeah
so listen they've been swearing up and
down that they never met with Russians
they never talk to Russians Russians
didn't help him with the campaign in any
way that's now undeniable
they've moved the goalposts to the
collusion wasn't illegal and instead she
says that it's others who are moving the
goalposts then she gets asked a specific
question by the bundling Steve Doocy
and she goes back to blame Hillary
Clinton but Kelly I'll call you up all
the time and say hey I got some dirt on
her and would you take a meeting with
them
the president said yesterday that kind
of occurrence happen all the time well
it does but in the case of Hillary
Clinton it was fair to say yeah let's
talk again about Hillary Clinton now
contrast this with what Kellyanne Conway
herself had to say in January listen to
how definitive she was here did anyone
involved in the Trump campaign have any
contact with Russians trying to meddle
with the election absolutely not and I
discussed that with the president-elect
just last night those conversations
never happened I hear people saying it
like it's a fact provision that is just
not only inaccurate and false is the
president what it does undermine our
democracy
nobody was involved there was no contact
we now have proof in writing so this is
bad enough but if you can believe it it
gets even worse she then went on ABC's
Good Morning America and claimed with a
straight face that the real problem here
is James commis leaking of information
that's the problem according to
Kellyanne Kellyanne what we have to go
the information was sought from the
campaign and those denials were allowed
to stand for many months that's the
bottom line
thanks very much you're done I wasn't in
the meeting I was in the meeting but
people amended their disclosure forms
and I think the big bombshell this
morning is Jim call me disclosing
confidential information conversations
you have as a friend I stated quote
private memos that's something Americans
should release oh yeah focus on that
these are Liars of the highest order
this is shameless dishonestly and at
this point it's indicative of panic and
a question for a lawyer would be at what
point if any legally speaking do
Kellyanne Conway's persistent public
lives become part of the cover-up would
you be willing to have a serious
conversation with Kellyanne conway cuz I
don't think I would be able to learn
oval projection shifting the goalposts I
mean there's
no intellectual honesty there and we
can't even agree on what the facts are
because she has alternative fact I would
have a serious conversation with her if
she were capable of doing that and less
substantive but just as wacky here is
Kellyanne Conway doing rhyming while
holding signs up on Fox News I just want
to review in case you run out of time
and this is how you see it so far this
is to help all the people at home what's
the conclusion
collusion no we don't have that yet I
see illusion and delusion so just over
clear everyone's forwards conclusion
collusion no illusion delusion yes I
just thought we'd have some fun with
words assessing these Grover where is
the day perhaps yeah when the
indictments come in I hope that she's
going to spend her time on something
other than picture sign of words on how
to fit whatever you would even call this
nonsense this is insane making it easy
for the fox news audience to understand
yes she had to speak for the lowest
common denominator
folks what is going on here I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
twitter at david pakman show follow me
there today's program is made possible
by taga dabbe the hosting specialists
offering a range of flexible hosting
packages including dedicated VPS and
cloud server options as well as custom
server solutions and uk-based colocation
services for your business or project
taga dad's web hosting services support
a wide range of customers and businesses
worldwide including bloggers tech
startups financial traders gamers web
developers and more and taga dad has a
really user-friendly interface so you
don't have to worry about being super
tech savvy they can automate almost
everything you need for total ease of
use they are really proud of their team
of expert hosting specialists who are
also their support team 70% of their
business comes from repeat orders and
recommendations with a growing number of
people interested in moving their
businesses and projects to the cloud
taga dab is currently offering our
viewers and listeners a twenty british
pound free credit about twenty four US
dollars to all customers signing up to
give you a chance to try the service
this is a
limited availability offer first-come
first-served for viewers and listeners
of the David Pakman show to take
advantage of it go to sign up CAG adapt
calm /t DPS and use the offer code TDPS
20 all one word all lowercase
during account registration